man tritt dem bahnübergang im
niedersächsischen holtgast nicht zu nahe
wenn man sagt er es nicht der
allerwichtigste rundherum felder und
wiesen
trotzdem ist der derzeit einer der
teuersten übergänge im gesamten
streckennetz weil es die deutsche bahn
nicht schafft ihren kaputten übergang zu
reparieren muss er rund um die uhr
bewacht werden
kostenpunkt rund 20.000 euro pro monat
hätte längst massives gelächter das
ammerland im nordwesten niedersachsens
saftige wiesen glückliche kühe eine
einzige idylle
doch im april 2016 nicht schluss mit
lustig eine feldmaus nähert sich dem
bahnübergang missachtet alle
warnschilder und knabbert an einem
wichtigen kabel die folge die
signalanlage gibt ihren geist auf am
bahnübergang geht nichts mehr
und jetzt schnell repariert und alles
ist wieder okay weit gefehlt
laut deutscher bahn ist der schaden
ihrer parabel die ersatzteile soll es
nicht mehr geben weil auf der
eingleisigen strecke aber viel
zugverkehr unterwegs ist muss der
bahnübergang abgesichert und bewacht
werden tag für tag rund um die uhr seit
über einem jahr
laut bahn musste übergang sogar komplett
erneuert werden
das wird allerdings noch etwas dauern
schriftlich heißt es es wurde bereits
die planung für eine neue anlage
begonnen
es schließt sich ein sogenanntes
planfeststellungsverfahren oder
plangenehmigungsverfahren beim
eisenbahnbundesamt an
dieses nimmt in der regel zwei bis drei
jahre in anspruch
zwei bis drei jahre ampel an ampel aus
weil die bahn den kabelschaden am
übergang irgendwo im nirgendwo nicht
reparieren kann
das geht nicht weil ich schätze mal so
ein ersatzteil so neu herstellen zu
lassen wir uns auch nicht mehr selber
hat wäre wahrscheinlich einiges billiger
verstehe ich auch dixies und es ist eine
zumutung einfach da steht auch die ganze
zeit alleine rum ich glaube nicht dass
es irgendwann mal schaffen werden
es wäre mal wünschenswert aber ich
glaube sie schaffen es nicht
es werden wohl noch einige sommer und
winter vergehen bis der übergang wieder
funktioniert wann das tatsächlich sein
wird steht in den sternen
für die nächsten jahre sind die jobs am
bahnübergang in holtgast jedenfalls
sicher